-Today's Friday, and that's usually when
I catch up on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox, I return some e-mails, and, of course,
I send out Thank You Notes,
and I was just running a bit behind today.
If you guys wouldn't mind, I'd like to write out
my weekly Thank You Notes right now.
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, could I get some
Thank You Note writing music, please?
♪♪
-Aww. First snow fall. -He's in a great mood.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you, New Year's resolutions,
for being a major life decision you make
when you're the drunkest you've been all year.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-State bird.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the state bird. -Yeah. Texas.
-You know, "New York Times"
won't say that's the joke of the week.
-No. -But it is.
-Yeah, it's the joke of the week.
What can I tell you? They're wrong.
-They're wrong. Yeah. -Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you, New Year's Eve glasses that form the year.
Listen, it made sense in the early 2000s,
but it might be time to just let things go.
I'm just saying. I...
Quite make sense.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Dry January,
for being the longest week of the year.
It was tough.
-I did it.
-Almost seven days. Almost.
-Oh, it's the second.
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, returning a Christmas gift,
for introducing us to the fun new game
"Is getting COVID worth 40 bucks?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"He'll never know I don't keep it."
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you, "The Book of Boba Fett,"
for being the worst thing a person can say
with food in their mouth.
[Muffled] Book of Boba Fett.
[ Applause ]
[ Steve laughing ]
♪♪
Thank you, Clayton Echard,
for sounding less like the newest Bachelor
and more like an eyeglass store competing with Warby Parker.
"Got these at Clayton Echard."
-Boop!
-Those the new Clayton Echards? -Yeah.
-They're pretty rad. -Bing!
-It's the last one. -It is?
-Yeah, for this -- for this episode.
-Oh, okay. You're gonna do more next week.
-What's that?
-You're gonna do some more next week. Maybe?
-Yeah. -Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah. -Yeah.
-Yeah. -But this is the last one.
-[As Bateman] We're gonna do that.
This is my Jason Bateman.
Yeah. Yeah. We're gonna do that.
Okay, okay, okay. Everyone calm down. Okay.
He's the host of "The Tonight Show."
Treat him with --
[ Laughter ]
Can we get some respect? Can we --
It's his last -- Gang. Can we just do the --
[ Laughter ]
-Where did that come from?! -Not bad?
-Yeah, that's good. -I'm working on it.
I'm working on it. Yeah, that's it.
-What other ones you working on? -I love Jason Bateman.
-He's a delight. -That's the one.
Blake Shelton I'm working on, too, a little bit.
[As Shelton] "Why the hell am I here?"
[ Laughter ]
"Why? Why? Why?"
That's all I got. [ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, ski boots,
for looking like a "Transformers" movie about Uggs.
There you have it, everybody. Those are our Thank You Notes.